[Musique]
bonjour à tous et bienvenue dans cette
nouvelle édition du Grand JIT des
territoires voici tout de suite les
titres de l'actualité d'une édition
largement consacrée au fit de fin
d'année au sommaire de ce journal notre
partenaire o TV la chaîne de la voie du
Nord proposera pour les retards à terire
des recettes pour un repas de fête
gastronomique au coup maîtrisé et puis
nous reviendrons sur les mesures prises
par le numéro 1 mondial du luxe qui
souhaite à l'issue de la COP 28
poursuivre ses efforts en matière de
réduction de son empreinte carbone à
Montpellier via occitan nous fera
découvrir une équipe d'enseignants qui
pour valoriser l'enseignement
professionnel a créé une équipe de motos
d'endurance pour disputer le Bol d'Or
rien que ça enfin avec VOG télévision
nous irons à la rencontre d'un Perne
Noël pas comme les autres puisqu'il
n'hésite pas à boucler sa valise pour
rendre visite aux enfants de Chandu en
Chine où il est accueilli à bras
ouverts au moment de faire les courses
nécessaires au repas de Noël la question
du coup se pose pour nombrees d'entre
nous je vous propose de découvrir
quelques recettes simples et économiques
avec Jérôme Oubron pour notre partenaire
o TV la chaîne de la voie du Nord
regardez pour les fêtes se faire plaisir
à table sans se ruiner relève parfois de
les e sportive ce matinl sur le marché
Damien les clients n'ont qu'une idée en
tête réduire la note dans l'assiette je
retireop pas facile quand la plupart des
produits ont vu leur prix exploser alors
chacun y va de son astuce disons qu'on
on regarde un peu les prix un peu
partout comme tout le monde nous d'abord
on est invité chez nos enfants mais on
donne chacun son son plat on apporte
chacun son plat bien manger sans se
ruiner le chef Jean-Michel desclous en
effit une spécialité dans son atelier le
chef nous propose une entrée alléchante
et à moindre coût finger de saumon fumé
au poivre de timut la recette commence
tout en gourmandisse par une ballotine
au fromage frais donc là c'est un
fromage frais que l'on peut trouver en
grande distribution c'est c'est Al faut
prendre un fromage frais nature voilà et
et de bonne qualité quant au saumon
produit coûteux quelques alternatives
existent on peut faire aussi cette
recette là avec du fléant fumé
voilà on peut partir puis fumer son son
son poisson soi-même si on veut donc là
la petite technique c'est de bien rouler
le saumon fumé pour faire un joli
ballotin une fois le ballotin bien serré
ne reste plus qu'à le laisser reposer au
froid quelques minutes le temps de
réaliser la sauce un mélange
d'ingrédients du quotidien mayonnaise et
moutarde aromatisé avec en option la
Voka avec modération des produits
simples et gourmands voilà la recette
d'une assiette à moindre frais pour ces
pickles d'oignons il ne faudra débourser
qu'à peine quelques centimes ce sont des
oignons avec un temps pourts vinaigre
eau et grenadine une très bonne
grenadine bien colorée ensuite je verse
ce liquide bouillant sur mes oignons
avec des épices l'Ance étoilé le clou de
girofle le bâton de cannelle du thint du
laurier ces épices qui nous rappellent
Noël quelques pétales
de mizuna coût total de cette entrée
festive un peu moins de 5 € ne manque
plus qu'un peu de moutarde japonaise
pour le piquan de pop-corn de Sarasin
pour le croquant et bien sûr un dressage
d'exception mais ça ça ne coûte
rien au moment des fêtes le dessert est
toujours un moment de débat du plus
simple au plus compliqué du plus
abordable au plus cher le choix est très
grand et à Paris la maison Hugo et
Victor a imaginé en collaboration avec
le joalier Lauren Baer une bûche colonne
vendô en hommage au monument parisiens
un reportage de Mélan fort pour 20
minutes TV regardez je vous présente la
bûche Hugo et Victor 2023 développée
avec mon ami le grand joiler lawence
Bomer explosion de gourmandis et de
fraîcheur
une bûche ça doit être gourmand et frais
à la fois pour la fin du repas donc vous
avez la mousse au Théol gré vous avez le
crémeux au Théol gré sur base de
chocolat au lait
qui est très très présent en thé on sent
à peine le chocolat le jus engelé à
l'orange le crémeux à l'orange et le
biscuit avec des éclats d'orange confit
cette bûche s'inspire de la colonne
vendom c'est un travail assez fin c'estz
délicat on a on a créé des moule on a
créé le moule du Napoléon et c'est vrai
qu'il y a eu plusieurs mois de
développement produit un développement
main dans la main avec lawence Baumer
installé place vendom cette colonne et
la muse du joyer indépendant leur
partition à qure mains comme ils aiment
la surnommer on peut prendre un diamant
brut et le retailler ça devient quelque
chose d'extraordinaire et j'ai retrouvé
dans les créations de HUG que je connais
depuis longtemps exactement ce désir et
pour les deux orfèvres de la pâtisserie
et de la joyerie Noël a une
signification singulière pour moi Noël
c'est une fête de famille le
couronnement d'un dîner de Noël c'est
évidemment le moment où arrive la bûche
et la source d'inspiration des deux
hommes se trouve à quelqu que maître de
la bijouterie la petite colonne
rencontre son aîné on retrouve la
colonne on retrouve Napoléon ici et là
le déroulé qui raconte la campagne
d'usterlitz c'était malgré tout assez
évident déjà le symbole de la place
vandom ta collection de photos
représentant la colonne vandom un clin
d'œil à la ville lumière le symbole de
Paris est là voilà un peu plus de 2
semaines après la COP 28 de Dubaï le
groupe LVMH a réuni à Paris les
dirigeants de ces 75 maisons pour faire
le point sur l'avancement de sa
politique environnementale alors si le
numéro 1 mondial du Lux a progressé dans
la réduction d'émissions de gaz à effet
de serre et dans la traçabilité de ces
matières premières il souhaite désormais
impliquer ses fournisseurs pour réduire
son empreinte carbone les explications
de Christophe Rigot qui était à
l'Unesco c'est dans le grand
amphithéâtre de l'UNESCO que le groupe
LVMH adressé un premier bilan de ses
engagements environnau pris en
2021 devant plus de 500 de ses
dirigeants et partenaires le numéro 1 du
luxe a réaffirmé ses convictions rien ne
serait pire que de réduire
l'environnement à une déclaration
d'intention et à des propos d'estrade
nous préférons les actes aux paroles
nous sommes conscients que ce sujet
vital est complexe il bouleverse des
équilibres des marchés voire des vies
aujourd'hui LV a notamment amélioré la
traçabilité de ces matières premières en
connaissant la presque totalité de
l'origine des diamants de la laine ou du
cuir de ses produits le groupe utilise
également des matières recyclées dans
ses emballages mais aussi pour ses
créations l'ensemble des maisons de LVMH
sont embarqué vers l'écoconception vers
une démarche de circularité appliquée à
nos produits ça veut dire l'utilisation
de matières recyclées de plus en plus de
matières biosourcé ça veut dire
également des services de répart
qui sinstle dans les maisons une maison
comme Louis Vuon par exemple répare plus
de 600000 pièces par an sur climat le
numéro 1 du luxe annonce avoir baissé de
11 % ses émissions de gaz à effet de
serre mais pour respecter ses
engagements à l'horizon 2030 LVMH devra
fournir des efforts importants notamment
sur les émissions indirectes du groupe
alors pour y parvenir il souhait
davantage impliquer ses fournisseurs et
ses partenairesz facile de l'interne et
de mobiliser ceux qui travaillent pour
nous en les formant en leur prêchant
quelque part la bonne parole et puis
cette conscience là tout le monde là
c'est assez évident en fait pour les
fournisseurs c'est plus difficile c'est
le fameux scope 3 qui qui est le le plus
lointain de nos activités en même temps
celui qui émet le plus de d'émission et
de gaz à effet de serre donc il faut
être en totale collaboration avec eux il
faut les
aider il faut les former ou travailler à
les former ensemble il faut les aider
financièrement et il faut travailler
avec eux le plus possible pour faire en
sorte que leurs objectifs et les nôtres
soient alignés la journée a été clôturée
par le ministre de la transition
énergétique Christophe Béchu et par un
défilé de mode unique en son genre avec
des vêtements réalisés à 100 % à partir
de matière
recyclé àim capitale de la porcelaine
s'interroge sur l'impact écologique de
son activité les morceaux défectueux et
cassés pourront à l'avenir être recyclé
et réemployé dans des céramiques
techniques pour l'automobile par exemple
ou l'aviation grâce aux recherches d'un
ingénieur céramiste qui a travaillé sur
le recyclage des déchets de porcelaine
dans les manufactures c'est un reportage
de cet alimo sur
place partagé entre la manufacture de
porcelaine coqué et l'incubateur
d'entreprise de l'Université de l'IM
Valentin Jaa vient de mettre au point
Sarah shape un procédé pour la
réutilisation des déchets porcelainers
ça ressemble bien à une véritable
révolution à la fin d'un projet avec le
laboratoire où on n pas pu forcément
industrialiser ce ce procédé à l'échelle
du laboratoire et donc on souhaitait la
création d'une start-up pour converger
naturellement vers vers le vers un
procédé comme ça qui soit industriel du
coup avec l'écosystème autour de l'IR de
et cetera on a convergé naturellement
vers le vers l'incubateur ce qui est
produit lors de lors des différentes
étapes de de production justement au
sein de de la manufacture donc c'est des
défauts des choses comme ça et donc ça
c'est traité comme des déchets ultimes
donc c'est des c'est déchets qui sont
enfouis la plupart du temps et donc nous
ce qu'on propose avec ce projet là c'est
de l'utiliser comme une nouvelle source
de matière première moi j'avais pas du
tout l'intention de de me lancer dans la
création d'une startup c'est
l'opportunité qui s'est qui s'est montré
à moi et et voilà j'ai j'ai eu la chance
de pouvoir travailler là-dessus à
Vaudreuil dans l'heure la journée
commence par un peu d'exercice pour les
écoliers chaque matin le school buus un
vélobus entièrement fabriqué en France
récupère les enfants de la commune pour
les amener à l'école puis les ramener
chez eux le soir un ramassage scolaire
ludique pratique et écologique qui a su
séduire les écoliers et les parents et
comme Nicolas de noïel l'a constaté pour
est France c'est un effort collectif
pour les enfants
ça au moins maman elle peut arrêter de
d'utiliser du de l'essence et comme ça
au moins on en a encore pour aller en
Bretagne super super idée c'est génial
ça Perm de PE faire des copains en plus
just très bien accompagné par le
monsieur qui est très gentil en plus
très sympa le vœux est renouvelé
régulièrement il faut valoriser
l'enseignement professionnel je vous
propose avec loï Tournier pour via
occitan de découvrir ce projet
pédagogique unique en France depuis près
de de 10 ans grâce à une équipe
d'enseignants très investis des lycéens
en section mécanique au lycé
pierreemandes- France de Montpellier
préparent tous les ans une moto pour
participer aux célèbres courses
d'endurance du Bol d'or ou d'argent
regarde vous le serrez à la main comme
ça mais après on le fera avec une clé
dynamométrique parce que c'est quand
même important de pas tout abîmer nous
ne sommes pas dans un atelier d'une
concession moto mais bien dans un lycée
sous les yeux de la ministre déléguée
chargée de l'enseignement et la
formation professionnelle les élèves du
lycée piermand France à Montpellier
présentent le projet Bol d'Or la célèbre
course auquelle ils ont participé avec
une moto préparée par leur soin
exceptionnel c'est des sensations qu'on
vit qu'une fois dans une vie quoi et
encore il y a des gens qui n'y vont
jamais qui qui savent pas ce que c'est
mais franchement il participer c'est
c'est vraiment quelque chose qu'on
souvient toute sa vie exceptionnel et
c'est une cohésion de groupe formidable
et ça nous apprend la vie depuis le mois
d'octobre en plus des CAP BTS et B pro
la section a ouvert cursus une formation
complémentaire d'initiative local projet
bal d'or se faisait qu'avec des élèves
et donc on avait expliqué à à notre
rerice que ça devenait compliqué et que
il fallait une formation vraiment à part
entière pour gérer ça ce sont les genses
de la FCIL qui travaillent sur
l'expertise du moteur Yam et qui
travaill maintenant sur le montage de la
nouvelle moto cette formation dure 1 an
et s'adresse à des personnes déjà
diplômées pour acquérir une
qualification spécifique à un domaine
professionnel on va renforcer
professionnellement les élèves et on va
les on va leur apprendre à préparer des
motau monter des motos de course à les
préparer et encadrer une moto sur un
circuit ça répond à des exigences
formulées par les professionnels et en
même temps que par les instances
fédérales comme la Fédération Française
moto qui sont à la recherche de
techniciens qui puissent encadrer les
écoles de pilotage puisque il y a une
explosion totale des roulages et des
écoles de pilotage en France la section
mécanique repartira en 2024 pour un
nouveau Bol d'Or avec une moto pensée
pour être écologique là on travaille
avec total ennergie sur un nouveau
carburant qui ne contient ni pétrole ni
éthanol et qui qui sera appelé à
remplacer les carburants de compétition
dans un avenir très proche en plus du
projet Bol d'Or au sein du lycée les
élèves sont en alternance ou en stage
dans des entreprises les tâes
principales ça peut aller de du simple
entretien sur les véhicules des motos
des scooters mais ça peut aussi aller
jusqu'à jusqu'à les opérations plus
techniques du remontage de véhicule
après sininistre en 2023 15 lycéens dont
6 BTS et 9 bac pro ont pris part au Bol
d'Or
2023 sans transition partons maintenant
découvrir loïque avec Canal 32 un
photographe installé dans l'Aube sa
particularité être non voyant un
handicap qui ne l'empêche pas de vivre
pleinement sa passion pour la
photographie en 2018 il ose montrer ses
photos à son entourage surpris par la
qualité de ses clichés ses proches
l'incitent à continuer aujourd'hui
Bertrand loï sonne les chemins de
randonnée il compose et écrit des textes
pour accompagner ses photos et ses
expositions regardez qu le chemin est
dégagé relativement large et que c'est
calme je peux tout lâcher et je le suis
au bruit de ses pas Bertrand loï a
progressivement perdu la vue depuis
l'enfance jusqu'à ses 20 ans son
compagnon de route est en photographe il
a osé faire comme lui grâce à un
smartphone ver la droite ouis voilà ni
voilà là il dit niveau là là je bouge
plus et j'appuie deux fois n'importe où
sur l'écran je ne vois que d'un seul œil
bah quand on se balade ensemble autour
du Montblanc par exemple on imagine un
œil pour quatre en fait si ses yeux
dfonctionnent en 2018 Bertrand loï se
décide à oser montrer ses photos
dissimulées dans son smartphone à une
collègue de confiance et elle m'a dit
Bertrand Bertrand faut pas que tu fasses
tes
photos depuis il expose ces tirage et il
a pu nouer une nouvelle complicité avec
son père qui photographiait jusqu'à ce
qu'il perde la vue son objectif
désormais consiste à partager son regard
son regard d'aveugle c'est marrant je
bouge un peu je sens comme un comme une
lumière qui change un peu il doit y
avoir soit une branche soit un nuage et
donc ça peut me donner envie ça toujours
attiré par l'art pertrin loï s'exprime
désormais par le biais de composition
musicale de prise de son ou de
l'écriture quand l'acte fait
sens spontané adéquit une joie reparaît
qui remplit sans pourquoi célébrant le
retour d'un incertain inscrit elle
impose le jour en défi à
l'ennui je veux peut-être montrer en
premier lieu que le regard d'une
personne non voyante
euh ben il est vivant c'est pas le noir
le blackout et rien du tout quoi son
regard de photographe est désormais mis
en lumière un groupe a sélectionné l'une
de ses photos comme pochette d'album et
il prépare de nouvelles expositions
ouvrons maintenant une large page
consacrée aux fêes de fin d'année faites
vous allez le voir qui permettent de
travailler sur l'insertion comme dans
cette recyclerie visitée par Clémence
degy et Clément du puit pour la Dépêche
du Midi ici près de Toulouse pour le
plus grand bonheur des familles qui
achètent à moindre coût ses jouou remis
à neuf des milliers de jouets d'occasion
retrouvent une seconde vie entre les
mains de salariés en parcours
d'insertion
professionnel le but c'est de rénover
des Jouines de les recycler et de les
revendre à des des prix solidaires on
emploie des personnes en insertion donc
c'est des personnes qui sont éloignées
de l'emploi et qui sont ici pour un
retour à l'emploi alors on a H8 salariés
en insertion
actuellement et du coup on a à peu près
3000 jeux à vendre en stock actuellement
aussi mais ça va vraiment dégrossir
d'ici 2 semaines et donc on a récolté 8
tonnes depuis le début du projet de jeu
et on a revendu à peu près 6000 jeux
depuis le début voilà et en î vilen
c'est un chantier d' verion
professionnelle qui prépare de
nombreuses animations et aussi des
décorations pour la ville de Redon
depuis une vingtaine d'années ces
chantiers événementiel permettent à des
salariés de courte durée de se lancer
dans l'artisanat pour TVR Natacha Astor
s'est rendu ce matin dans leurs ateliers
regardez on entre un peu dans les
coulisse des Lutins de Noël maises
versions redonnaise ici on s'occupe des
vareuses que porteront les animateurs
d'AC ité lou vient d'entamer il y a 2
jours son contrat de 26h par semaine
j'ai d'autres projets à côté et
l'avantage d'être ici bah c'est de
d'apprendre à faire des choses sympas
parce qu'il y a plein de d'ateliers
différents ici d'avoir une situation
stable pour du coup au moins 6 mois pour
avoir le temps de moi j'ai prévu de
passer mon permis menuiserie sérigraphie
mais aussi décoration tout est fait main
dans la bonne humeur et avec des objets
de récupe comme ces panneaux de
Signaléthique photomaton et jeux en bois
cette année les décos sont sur le thème
de l'eau pour célébrer Redon ville entre
fleuves et canot ça c'est chouette quoi
parce que en fait ça passe d'un atelier
à un autre bon ici nous des fois on dit
ah stop on a plus de place mais en effet
voilà ça passe de la structure pour
aller en déco ou en sérégraphie après ça
revient à la déco ça peut repartir en
couture parce que il y a des accessoires
de de tissu à mettre ce chantier
d'insertion appelé lever le rideau est
un trempelin pour l'insertion ou la
reconversion professionnelle il permet
aussi au 22 salariés de faire des stages
ou des formations à côté de leur contrat
allant de 4 mois à 2 ans tout le monde a
parfois des des coups un peu durs dans
la vie donc c'est l'occasion de
reprendre confiance en soi
et redresser la tête et avancer et après
c'est aussi le plaisir d'être avec les
autres de de rencontrer de nouvelles
personnes de faire des nouvelles amitiés
les animations de l'association lafédés
seront à voir sur les places de Bretagne
et de la République à Redon les trois
weekends avant
Noël entre novembre et décembre c'est
plus de 2 millions de colis qui seront
livrés quotidiennement à travers l'une
des 19 plateformes du groupe la poost un
volume vertigineux qui nécessite de
nouveaux matériels alors pour répondre à
la demande la plateforme historique de
beggle en Gironde est progressivement
remplacé par une structure ultra
mododerne à cadeau jaacqu notre
partenaire TV7 la chaîne du groupe
sud-ouest l'a visité pour nous regardez
des colis des centaines de milliers de
colis à en donner est presque le tourn
on décharge les colis sur l'encamionneur
ils vont suivre le tapis pour monter
jusque l'injection du du triilleur le
triilleur c'est la grande nouveauté au
cœur de cette immense fourmilière un
tapis roulant nouvelle génération de
plus d'un km capable de trier deux fois
plus de colis que sur la plateforme
historique de bgle ça ça n'existait pas
on est de l'ordre de 9 à 10000 colis par
heure ici on trie en moyenne 19000 colis
par heure on peut faire des pointes
supérieures à 000 comme on a pu faire
pas plus tard cet après-midi le site de
bgle installé depuis une trentaine
d'années est donc aujourd'hui trop petit
et obsolète pour suivre la cadence il
sera définitivement fermé en mars 2024
et ses 130 salariés seront rapatriés ici
sur cette plateforme de 22000 m car à la
pointe de la technologie et dans le
tunnel de lecture on va récupérer
l'ensemble des faces du collier on va
les prendre en photo on va aussi prendre
des mesures du colis le poids du colis
et enfin les informations sur
l'étiquette nous avions en fait sur ble
des personnes en fait qui devaient
encoder des informations sur le sur le
colis alors qu'ici c'est fait de façon
automatique avec ce avec ce ce tunnel
cette nouvelle plateforme de tri et de
livraison couvre ainsi l'intégralité du
Sud-Ouest coût de l'investissement 40
millions d'euros elle est destinée à
trier près de 50 millions de colis par
an 40 millions de colis dès l'année
prochaine elle va trier environ 120000
colis par jour et durant les fêtes de
fin d'année tout s'accélère avec plus de
300000 colis triés chaque
jour pour livrer les cadeaux de Noël il
y a la poste mais le père Noël reste
encore le moyen le plus sûr Alain
Simonin ce bûcheron vugogien en retraite
en dos depuis plusieurs années le
costume du Père Noël destination
chengdou 16 millions d'habitants dans la
province de chichuan où il n'était pas
retourné depuis 2019 en raison de la
crise sanitaire là-bas on l'accueille à
chaque fois les bras ouverts c'est à
Gérard m chez lui et peu de temps avant
son départ que nous l'avons
rencontré la dernière fois c'était en
2019 il n'y était pas retourné depuis en
raison de la crise sanitaire mais ce
jeudi à gérardmé c'était enfin l'heure
pour le Père Noël géromois de préparer
sa valise en vue de son prochain départ
non comme on aurait pu le penser pour la
Laponie mais pour la Chine destination
shengdu 16 millions d'habitants dans la
province du Suan et il a hâte toujours
aant la première année je pleurais de
joueur parce que je suis parti de Pékin
où j'avais eu un choc culturel énorme
j'avais rien compris à ce que ma
présence représentait là-bas j'ai
compris bien après donc maintenant je
pleure de tristesse quand je m'envis
j'ai une une haie d'honneur pour sortir
de l'hôtel et chaque employé de l'hôtel
me donne une une rose le bouquet de
rouge que je peux avoir et la dernière
fois 2019 et bien ils ont euh ils ont il
ils avaient bloqué la porte c'est-à-dire
que personne ne pouvait sortir ni
rentrer tant que je n'étais pas sorti
moi et il y avait le président
d'azerbaïjan voilà j'ai toujours du mal
à le dire qu' voulait sortir il l'ont
ils ont il ont dit d'attendre que le
Père Noël soit sorti normal aucun homme
fustil d'État n'est audessus du Père
Noël dans les affaires de cet ancien
bûcheron géromois quelques
indispensables photos de ses proches et
bien sûr son fameux costume et à ce
propos mon costume de P no ne convient
pas au niveau de la couleur pass assz
rouge j'ai d oui mais il faud prévoir
des Brutelles B il m m des bretelles lou
Vuon voilà bon ça sera pas mieux que les
les MI
que j'ai Aché dans une grande surface
mais voilà même si ses hutes sont au
petit soins pour lui les journées
d'Alain Simonin sont là-bas plutôt
chargé entre visite de consulat
d'entreprise ou d'école et d'ailleurs il
se souvient d'une fois où 3000 enfants
lui ont souhaité un joyeux Noël les
gamins se sont levés
et j'ai cru que les vitres des bâtiments
à côté allent explosé tellement ça fait
un bruit un bruit retour de Chine le 29
décembre prochain à avec d'autres
souvenirs
inoubliables vous avez peut-être décoré
votre maison de guirlande lumineuse et
de Père Noël malicieux ce weekend
dites-vous que certains poussent la
démarche à son paroxisme c'est le cas
d'ériic Boyer et de sa famille qui
prépare les décoration depuis août
dernier et le résultat en vaut la peine
découvrer une maison entièrement
illuminée avec près de 3 km de guirlande
visite guidée avec marieelis parillot
pour TL7 dans la Loire dans la on voit
[Musique]
qu'elle la maison d'éc Boyet est
rayonnante pour les fêtes de fin d'année
au total 40000 lumières forme ce
spectacle alors contraement ce qu'on
peut per il y a beaucoup de lumière
mais moi ça me coûte sur l'ensemble du
mois que j'éclaire ça me revient à 50 €
voil de plus simpement c'est tout des
Lumières
pendant la moitié de l'année avec sa
famille il prépare les scènes PL croquis
il faut bien tout ce temps car beaucoup
de décors sont fait mains toutes les
années on a toujours peur
d'être d'être à la traain quoi
et bon mais ça le fait ça le
[Musique]
fait donc le moulin fait maison aussi
moulin bonhomme de neige tout est fait
pour
émerveiller ils ont souris
parfois il y en a qui veulent faire
plusieurs tours mais bon même les grands
les grands aussi hein ils adorent chaque
année il y a des nouvelles il y a des
nouveautés c'est un petit peu amélioré à
chaque fois c'est c'est incroyable quoi
toujours plus déjà que c'est magnifique
et il en rajoute une petite couche on
sait pas comment il fait mais ouais
c'est
splendide Éric Boyet ouvre sa maison
jusqu'au 7 janvier aux visiteurs et leur
offre même quelques friandises et
collation en repartant ils sont invités
à laisser un mot dans le livre d'or
toujours le promet Eric rempli de beaux
compliments voilà c'est la fin de cette
édition il me reste à vous souhaiter de
très belles fêtes de Noël merci à vous
de nous avoir suivi on se retrouve très
vite pour une nouvelle édition du Grand
JIT des territoires au revoir à tous et
bon
[Musique]
Noël I